j'accueille maintenant orlando
orlando bonsoir soir alors en fait vous
appelez bruno gigliotti j'ignore qui
veut dire le lis exact voilà alias
orlando et vous êtes le frère cadet de
dalida dont vous avez été le producteur
de 1970 à 1985 aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui vous êtes son légataire 1 en
fait
orlando s'est pas votre vrai nom c'est
nom de votre frère aîné exact vous vous
appelez bruno fuchs et la soirée c'est à
dire que les visas belges moi c'est mon
vrai nom ouais vous c'est effectivement
donc bruno et vous avez pris ce pseudo
d'orlando les emprunter au moment où
vous êtes tenus en france dans les
années 60 trois 64 alors avant d'être en
france détient l'egypte 1 au caire dans
le quartier de choubra votre père qui
s'appelait pietro était violoniste et à
l'opéra du caire et votre mère
giuseppina s'occuper de la maison
voilà donc une famille du quartier de
choubra votre père est mort à ces jeunes
très jeunes je les vois pratiquement pas
connu
est ce que c'est parce que pendant la
guerre en tant qu'italien mussolinien il
avait été arrêté par les anglais au
caire oui ça a dit que tous les italiens
avaient été internés à cette époque la
dentelle comme après décompte des
centres concentration je me rappelle
très bien que le vivent toutes les
femmes des des internats italien de
reprendre un autobus vers 3 4 heures du
matin dans un de vos spéciale du caire
et tout le monde monte pour arriver à
fayed c'était fayed l'école et fayed
ça devait être loin seulement parce que
mon parti très tôt pour arriver elle
avait dix jours disons vers 9 heures du
matin et voltaire penser que c'est ça
qui l'a tué son incarcération et les
sorties les morts tout de suite moins
c'est ça alors dalida elle avait très
peu connue aussi elle croyait qu'elle
l'aimait pas son père un et ont
peut-être que sa quête d'hommes pendant
toute sa vie peut-être c'est justement
pour remplacer son père parce que là à
travers tous les hommes de sa vie elle a
recherché le père ouais elle voulait
sublimer le super l'intérêt qu'elle
croyait qu'elle n'est même pas du tout
et alors ces mots là ils surveillent les
hommes à leur plus haut les placer
de l'ol est tombé quant à elle cherchait
inaccessible et accessible chercher
l'absolu attendent donc vierge très
tortueux là alors vous passez votre
adolescence en egypte où vous chanter
c'est vous qui avez créé mustapha
j'étais un adolescent et mustapha ça a
été repris par volvo basam c'est un
succès énorme
bah oui alors milieu des années 60 vous
débarquez à paris pour réussir vous
aussi une carrière dans la chanson comme
comme votre soeur qui était déjà une
star elle en fait au départ au caire
elle voulait être secrétaire et puis
elle a eu un problème aux yeux elle
avait était tombé d'une maladie doivent
talmi au caire que c'était une maladie
courante au caire et le docteur a fait
une énorme faute lui a bandé les yeux
pendant 40 jours et quand on a enlevé le
bandage vers les ou qui louche et oui il
était normalement oui ma mère c'était
devenu mon père voulait tuer comme la
contribution jeté par mon père voulait
tuer les docteurs on allaite opéré à
trois aux nôtres c'est ton est donc et
après la porte et cela oblige à porter
des lunettes
jusqu'à l'âge de 15 saisons ouais et
celle d'hier quelconque quelque sorte et
enel s'était mis en place tout de suite
le deuxième avait gardé une certaine
faiblesse
et puis comme s'il avait une revanche à
prendre dans la vie elle qui pensait
qu'elle était laide et fils à mesure que
grandit c'est les formes ses formes et
commencer à voir que le regard change et
la sueur et puis un jour elle a pris ses
lunettes il a dit les a jetés par la
fenêtre le dis jamais plus je portais
des lunettes et elle s'est présentée au
concours à l'époque de miss ondine avant
de se présenter trois ans plus tard a
mis ses gîtes pour se prouver à
elle-même comme un défi que les prévenus
belle elle a gagné à sa grande surprise
elle a gagné le prix de la presse a
publié les photos de dalida en maillot
ça fait un scandale
dans la famille dans la famille c'est le
cas de le dire ensuite à la travaille
dans une maison de couture chez daunat
où elle a appris le métier de mannequin
et en 54 donc elle devient dalida miss
egypte elle commence à faire un peu de
cinéma et c'est là que son destin va se
jouer parce que dans la salle il y avait
trois hommes il y avait metteur en scène
l'égyptien et metteur en scène français
marc de gay marié de gastines et mettre
en scène américaine qui tournait à
l'époque le film joseph et ses frères
alors ces trois hommes et le metteur en
scène égyptienne va la faire jouer dans
un film où tu as joué les rôles d'une
italienne qui vont plein docteur lê le
français va l'amener en haute egypte
c'est comme ça que tu arrives à
découvrir la terre des pharaons vraiment
et pour être une espionne une sorte de
mata hari dont l'élément 74' et
l'américain va l'amener aussi en haute
egypte pour faire la doublure de l'hôtel
est ensuite à john collins oui voilà et
là donc marque de gastines l'a fait
venir en france et elle prend l'avion
c'est insensé le 24 décembre 54 avec
vingt mille francs de l'époque en poche
et deux ans après elle fait des numéros
1 de demain à l'olympia dans la salle il
ya là aussi encore une fois 13 ans
l'oiseau moqueur qui décide de sa
destinée trois hommes à paris bruno
coquatrix qu'il ouvrira les portes
l'olympia lycée maurice qui va
l'annoncer qui deviendra son époux eddie
barclay qui va lui signer un contrat qui
donnons 4,8 c'est jusqu'à 14 ans et
contre le quitteront définitive quand on
décidera de le quitter ce ne serait pas
une infidélité
parce que leur été fidèle pendant 14 ans
et ensuite c'est pas qu'elle valait dont
j maisons concurrentes parce qu'on a
offert disons d
cachez promis ne ou des primes et le
montre avec moi est sa propre maison
sera le premier producteur indépendant
donc de voir laurent vous voulez voulait
répéter là oui je vais le répéter mais
je voulais qu'on parle de michaël blanc
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure oui je
vais mon 7 thors et mon hôte d'or je
vais les mettre aux enchères sur
internet de façon à ce que l'argent de
la vente du 7 d'or soit pour nous caler
ben écoute moi je crois déjà dit oui
pour le 7 d'or dont auf ein c'est une
première enchère
merci l'or en espérant sauver
donc vous vous n'avez pas le succès
escompté dans la chanson en france et
vous décidez de vous occuper d'elle en
67 vous rentrez chez barclays et vous
devenez son directeur artistique après
coup d'une boîte international show qui
donnera relandeau production après vous
vous occupez vous êtes l'un des premiers
producteurs indépendants en france
vous lancez aussi les vagabonds indra et
maintenant ils viennent ségara il ya une
mélodie aussi mais l'échec mais logique
jadot absolument acquis et tout ça
absolument ils ont la perle dix ans de
l'écurie c'est le ségala bien dites moi
pourquoi vous êtes le producteur de ses
producteurs de la saga pourquoi vous
refusez qualité dans cette émission mais
je ne refuse pas ma tante et au j'étais
bien raison vous m'avez donné la vie
dure les jours vous avez donné une très
bonne raison excusez moi que je récupère
l'autre soir la première question que
vous avez posé alain alors à quel âge
vous avez fait je vais demander ça s'est
réglé pourquoi mon nom
elle viendra en temps voulu ça ne sais
pas mais vous êtes quand vous que je
pêche peut être parce que ces genres
d'émissions je perds deux fois que les
artistes peuvent déraper voilà qu'elle
se lâche et bien j'ai un tel mauvais
souvenir de la télévision je passe
souvent c'est pour ça que je suis sur le
medad
ça non plus qu'est ce qui vous était
arrivé quelques souvenirs je vais pas
revenir à l'appel tous de cette fameuse
émission le jeu de la vérité
ouais avec quelqu'un vous savez que
juste un mot ça avait suffi une soirée
et mots qui était passé à côté pour
l'eau chaude voyage sabatier je ne
voulais pas un engin l'année que j'aime
beaucoup derrière je me souviens
passagers bien et que quand même ça mis
en danger ce torrent qu'hélène ségara je
vous invite officiellement dans quinze
jours dans cette efficient pourquoi vous
savez quelle merde envie de venir
moi je ne me lasserai pas de vous tenez
je sais je sais tout à fait mais
d'ailleurs j'en suis tout à fait t'as
fait conscient donc aujourd'hui en
landau vous êtes le légataire de dalida
alors évidemment il ya deux versions de
vos activités il ya ceux qui disent que
vous faites une exploitation éhontée de
ses tubes en faisant des remixes divers
et variés à toutes les sauces
et puis à votre version à vous qui dit
je ne veux pas qu'on enferme dalida dans
un sarcophage en faisant des remixes y
chante dépenses du poids new way
parce que si je voulais faire de
l'argent je n'avais qu'à vendre les
version originale tard il faut passer
maintenant de l'édition originale
resteront toujours et pour l'éternité
c'est celle qui se vendraient plus et
que les gens recherchent les phénomènes
des mixages ces deux phénomènes de mode
des trois ans à tous a dit que tous les
trois autres 14 j'ai créé une actualité
au tour de l'ain dalida pour l'
excellent et l'étude de dalida dans
l'ère du moment où il faut pas oublier
carré d'as et pas simplement une artiste
sellamoutou masseur doit en aucun cas je
voudrais travailler ça alors là il ya un
nouveau remix donc ils s'appellent c'est
comment on fait avec les mains orlando
révolution alors hollande où on l'a dit
tout à l'heure dalida chercher un peu
son père à travers les hommes donc et
lucien morisse qui était le directeur
artistique d'europe 1 pour elle - qui
s'est suicidé quand même oui mais il
faut remettre les choses à leur place
quand il se suicider et il ne vivait
plus avec dalida ça faisait déjà 10 ans
qui s'étaient séparés même s'il a
toujours été amoureux des alida alors
elle l'a quitté pour jean sobieski c'est
qu'ils en sont exclus il faut se mettre
cette femme n'était arrivé et n'avait
qu'une idée en tête réussir et ne penser
car ici et la capacité pour réussir
toute sa vie elle était du genre jusqu'à
qu'elle arrive à être dalida elle s'est
mariée et le disons que l'amour avec lui
si elle avait vécu avant de se marier
elle a aimé pendant cinq ans au moment
de son mari elle n'émet plus et il y
avait 10 bon c'était comme une sorte de
reconnaissance mais de façon cet amour
et cette amitié se démentira jamais être
dans le haut rhin et la langue contre ce
garçon au festival de cannes c'était lui
c'est maurice était débarqué l'été
partir de caddies et nicole berkel à
l'époque et a eu le coup de foudre parce
qu'avec ce touch blanc d'une grande
beauté comme nous exprime une attelle
c'est vrai que là il a toujours regretté
par la suite rhin alors il y avait aussi
après jean ce biais ski et luigi tenco
qui était un chanteur italien qui avait
écrit avec elle une chanson pour le
festival de chanson de san remo ou
défendu ensemble l'agent défendu
ensemble la chanson dalida qui était
déjà comme une grande star détester les
festivals
elle l'a été par amour elle est
simplement pour les fonds de sa chanson
pour le nom c1 et lui qu'ils ont fait
dix ans que la chanson est éliminé il
s'est senti en quelque sorte un peu
responsable par la hauteur d'eau sur
et alors et c'est aïda quel contrat est
éliminé il est rentré à l'hôtel et se
suicider c'est là qu'il a trouvé sur la
tête remarqué dans son tempo si c'est
une fatalité c'est fou mais elle
d'ailleurs à la file longue série de
tentatives de suicide
dalida et là c'est la tombe de mettre
fin à ses jours et mois après jour pour
jour après qu'elle a découvert le ginkgo
son fiancé mans et s'est suicidé et
l'attenté de ce système là pour elle dit
toujours qu'elle était morte quand elle
avait sa première tentative de suicide
après celui de luigi tenco elle est
restée longtemps en commun elle restait
six jours et les ensuite il a été trois
mois parce que vous savez qu'il a été
découvert il avait tout le monde
j'imagine que vous savez qu'elles sont
son talon qui était posée par terre à la
une nécrose du talon la différence
il a fallu prendre de la peau dans son
pubis pour refaire son exactement bravo
alors il ya eu aussi le comte de saint
germain richard chanfray vous dire
qu'elle est à les accumuler quand même
votre soeur non vous savez que je pense
qu'une chose qui est des destins celui
quand même c'est un tifo dire nos
amitiés spectateurs les plus jeunes qui
disait qu'il était immortel enfin
savamment extravagant mais avant vous
savez ce qui est devenu aujourd'hui la
preuve vous voyez que s'il n'est pas
immortel puisqu'il est mort il est mort
a lui aussi hérité rang c'est quoi
l'histoire landau non parce que visa
bête on l'a accusé d'avoir eu des
relations coupables avec françois
mitterrand qu'on y est
mais françois mitterrand et toute sa
famille ensuite en 1974 et d'aller
j'avais une concrète du parti social il
ya sont de chair gaston donnât
s'interrompt à marseille ont invité des
leaders à dîner oui moi la faute il pu
peut-être fond il m'a dit qu'il vivait
rond point il aimait les belles femmes
et donc je la seule chose que dalida
tellement rigolé zadkine je pense que il
s'est arrangé pour que gaston defferre
invite dalida elle qu'elle n'avait pas
l'habitude du fatah fait terminer son
tour de chant elle partait à l'hôtel si
elle a dit est ce que ce serait pas mal
si vous venez dîner avec nous ce soit
donc c'est une volonté il n'y a pas eu
de franchement ça je ne pourrai pas de
répondre malheureusement n'est plus là
pour le dire et moi vous savez comme je
dis toujours j'aimerais toujours bord de
la porte je n'ouvre jamais la porte
quand je ne suis pas offrir ce que
voulait pas dire mais un mitterrand
mitterrand avec un brin de visiter des
leaders dans la maison de mon mari mais
elle est là mais il y avait beaucoup de
monde
non mais il se retrouver tous les deux
auraient besoin de moments il a écouté
pourquoi voulez toujours voir quelque
chose rien d'y aller comme ça qu'est ce
que j'y fais pas un soleil d'études mais
vous savez c'est cela une pub lescure ça
orlando vous êtes un producteur du show
business et vous ne serez pas étonné que
nous vous fassions une interview
moralité on à gauche pendant les clients
ne bouge pas pendant le génial on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle bravo merci
alors à l'époque où vous habitiez au
caire dans le quartier de choubra est ce
que il vous est arrivé de piqué dans le
porte-monnaie de votre maman juice
épines
oui oui mais de petites choses tout
petit piastres oui mais bon c'est déjà
une habitude qui nous ne voulons pas du
tout non non pas du tout ce sont les
plus élevés le porte-monnaie et ouvert
qui avait une petite pièce qui tenait
comme ça je voulais pas lui faire de la
peine
vous gagnez vous voyez le tome vous
gagner au loto
le billet ne vous appartient pas qu'est
ce que vous faites et les gens tout de
suite
alors là c'est clair et net donc un
estonien superbe et généreux d'accord
orlando vous trouvez un porte-monnaie
dans la rue avec de l'argent dedans
est-ce que vous rendez les papiers
je n'ai même pas moi même au commissaire
âge je dirais avec des amis ou en dedans
allait porter ses portes au mena non ça
m'intéresse pas d'accord vous êtes plein
de blé en même temps aussi
non j'ai jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
il est donc un commerçant se trompe en
vous rendant l'amener est-ce que vous
lui fait remarquer oui et je peux vous
regarde et on le disait quelqu'un pour
délit non non non alors si c'est un
commerçant que vous aimez pas dans un
quartier vous n'avez jamais évidemment
votre boulanger view dit bonjour tous
les matins et des mois vous lui dites je
regardais vous êtes trompés dans
l'immédiat je voudrais pas le faire
maintenant suite je n'ai fait rugir les
frères et marqué oui oui à 60 ans même
heure et à quoi un accord une petite
vengeance est alors je préfère leur dire
ce que je pense en face à sanaa capable
tout est ce qui vous arrive de faire les
poches de la personne avec qui vous
vivez voyage être honnête voilà je n'ai
pas l'habitude de les faire mais une
fois j'avais fait voilà vous êtes vous
avec ce qui se passe je suis arrêté par
la suite voilà dans ces cas là ce qui
est terrible c'est qu'on tombe sur des
numéros + une fois après on appelle j'ai
regretté par la suite
la banque se trompe de dix mille francs
en votre faveur
voilà vous recevez votre relevé de
banque et vous comprenez qu'il ya dix ou
cent mille ou un million est ce que vous
appelez la banque en lisant vous êtes
trompé de toute façon je ne dirai rien
parce que toute façon le nouveau centre
alors il faudrait que tu fais pas le
même allant chez lui au moins je
l'espère ensablé plaisir simplement
qu'ils se sont trompés mais son ballon
du silence
et si l'employé qui a fait l'erreur qui
est un père de famille qui viennent 7000
francs par mois il a trois enfants il
est viré à cause de ça le grand plat
très lassant si c'était ça donne aux
médias de façon qu'il ya une chose que
même si nous sommes trompés
je resterai une semaine après j'aurai
mois maximum après je ferai bien sûr ça
va pas de soi même ça va de soi mais
toute façon c'est rare
il ne serait plus jamais ça s'appelle we
sing quelques jeunes esprits alors voilà
imagine
et vous possédez un appartement qui vous
appartient vous le loup et je vous ai
pas envie d'y habiter et le locataire ne
peut plus payer le loyer
c'est un type horrible vraiment c'est un
type détestable il a deux gosses
insupportable il peut plus payer le
loyer sa femme vous incite chaque fois
qu'elle vous voit est ce que vous le
foot est dehors je pense que oui ah
ouais vous le film les insultes
je serai masoala à la rigueur je
prendrai mes enfants je ne sais pas je
vous appellerai quelqu'un pour qu'ils
s'occupent des enfants mais non plus les
enfants m'insulte aussi au salon
il ya une histoire terrible je vous fait
la une des médias faisaient en
couverture de france-soir du parisien du
figaro de tous les canards parce que
vous avez sauvé une petite fille d'un
incendie est en fait vous savez bien que
c'est pas vous qui l'avait sauvé que le
pompier qui l'a sauvée il est mort le
pour brûlé carbonisé terrible est ce que
vous dites est ce que vous dites vous
êtes trompé c'était pas moi
ou est ce que vous dites bonjour
couverture du journal je suis un héros
après tout merde j'ai l'habitude pas
d'être le convertir - dernière page va
serait pas besoin de ça mais c'est la
moindre des choses serait de rendre
justice surtout quelqu'un qui est mort
on construit on m'a viré par le pauvre
ont bien été obligés en janvier pour sa
famille on voit qu'il voit qu'il est
mort pas pour rien mais on n'est pas
d'accord
donc vous êtes assez a quand même pour
un producteur je veux dire pas du tout
ce sont des gens très bien je connais
pas sauf que nous tout le monde le sait
mais alors un mec vous a doublé sur
l'autoroute quand vous humilie angers
direz vous a fait en passe en effet
comme ça là et là elle a dit vous a
doublé puis bon et vous le retrouvez
vous le retrouver après après la sortie
de l'autoroute vous le retrouvez sur une
route départementale en panne est ce que
vous vous arrêtez pour ce cours est
peut-être que je suis là tu es comme
vous dites grossier je m'arrêterai pas
mais je m'arrête je voudrais quelqu'un
d'autre ou j'appellerai pour dire je
t'aime pas évident que moi même je le
ferai pas question difficile
vous trouvez un nourrisson abandonné sur
votre paillasson chez vous et alors vous
vous l'adoptez ou si leur féline a fait
quoi
difficile mais pour adopter l'enfant
c'est une énorme responsabilité
vous savez il faut s'en occuper je ne
sais pas si je serais si j'espère une
bonne personne parce que tu admires pour
lui de vivre avec vous qui est
financièrement assez aisée vous pouvez
lui a quand même il peut aller à l'école
il peut faire alors que sinon c'est
l'orphelinat
c'est trop facile de répondre comme ça
parce qu'on est à la télévision de dire
non je répondrais j'adopterai c'est pas
vrai je vais pas répondre ça d'abord
j'ai pas été confrontés à un tel
problème à la gorge et pas même si je la
mettrais quelques passes assez réfléchi
à cela les des îles et îlots où le
trouver mais moi dire des dirigeants
pour faire bien dire oui je l'avais la
docteure je ne sais pas je peux pas me
chercher des excuses à des sprints
chercher des excuses nous laisser tout
seul à l'orphelinat ont pas tout seul
pas tout seul enfin oui tout ça alors
qu'ils devraient chase 1k plusieurs
fenêtres donc ils sont plusieurs
en messieurs
/
pas plus bas
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
nourriture abonnez vous il m'était
impossible